imaginez une université j'ai le droit
d'être unique parmi des milliers
d'autres où j'aime apprendre et où
j'apprends ce qu'elle est maintenant on
va péter ça ça vaut le thème les jeunes
chantent 6 et 8 août toutes et tous
étaient en tort
ap jake sully or je vais devenir tireurs
d'élite ont cassé la main tu perds tes
poils et quitter tiger pas bu boira oui
on en reparle à la fin de l'année je
vais mettre quelques longueurs de
terrain arrive au concours pas vraiment
dans la même catégorie
leur cafétéria vous propose chaque jour
un repas complet
venu au cours de terreur premier niveau
pas la terreur
salut à tous les vrais ils appâtent 1 je
suis sûr que tu vas te trouver de petits
copains et aux gabarits ça vous dirait
d'entrer chez les rouges marc a pas on a
même à gâteau c'est de mettre un
défraiement
pouvez-vous prétendre être le monde je
m'appelle carte pratique le zen
macrobiotique tenez je vous ai préparé
un cahier pour noter vos rêves
c'est pas drôle
les jeux de la peur une compétition
hyper impressionnant
tu peux carrément iris 3 a beaucoup si
vous échouez vous serez tous
exclu de l'université
bon d'accord ni camarades d'ousmane apa
jeu nantais supplémentaire le ménage des
potions - c'est parti pour la première
compétition bonne chance lépi merci on
peut vous massacrer
des tentacules été ventouses salle en gt
n'entrez pas
tu fasse remonter toute la terreur qui
est engagée
ce soir on va semer la terreur
je vais être en retard le jour de la
rentrée